But the one thing I do want to talk about actually on the flight out to it got
so delayed, but on the flight out to, um,
where was I going, dude? This is unbelievable. Just wait for this.
I got to go to our text chain, cause this is where it was here, dude. They got,
so we got, we were so delayed to go to,
into we're flying into New York from Albuquerque.
I was just me. Um,
and we were so delayed that they, they,
this flight was crazy. All right. It was from Minneapolis, I think,
to new JFK and
the F you decide this because, uh, the,
the stewardess,
or I don't know if they just call them stewards now because you know,
the times are changing, but
she was so she sounded so drunk.
It was unbelievable, dude. Okay. Susan's talking about it is, you know, again,
I have, you're going to have your, your, your,
your chairs up in an upright assessment and it's all good.
Like that's what she was saying, upright Zishan. So, um,
this is the that she was saying here. Uh,
you decide if she's drunk or not, dude. Okay. You decide.
[Inaudible] until the two is fully extended, please. Over your nose around.
So that the last six round hole you're having to adjust a mask is necessary
breathe normally. And the oxygen is flowing.
Even if the fact is not afraid to secure your own mask before helping others
ox is your master to okay. In it, in the overhead panel and the laboratory.
Instead of carrying it on, basically make sure to get it. And then it's, I said,
Jen, I said, Jen dude, so drunk.
And then she would walk down and I'd be like, trying to smell this girl.
I'm like, did you have alcohol? And I was trying to look at her.
She didn't look drunk, dude. She was like, 50 dude.
I couldn't believe it. I saved this. And there's another one. Hold on. Okay.
And then I, and then I thought maybe, and then some weird was going on.
And this dude, Oh dude,
I was sitting at a bar before because the flight was delayed so much.
I got salmon because you know, I'm healthy babies. You know how I do it.
And this dude was sitting next to me and he was
so loud and he was drunk and he was just,
he would do, he would laugh. He would be like, Oh, cause you know, Tom Brady,
yada, yada, like so loud. And then he would laugh and he'd go, Oh, Oh, Oh.
And I was like, Oh, I, I was like, I want it to knock this guy out. Right.
But that was like, maybe he's got a problem. It's all good. You know,
maybe he's got a drinking problem. And as you know, I, I feel for that. Right.
So we were so late. And then we,
we exited the gate and were about to take off.
And then the pilot goes like this. Uh, so ladies, gentlemen,
we got to go back to the gate. There's something with customer service.
And I just go, I, I rolled my eyes so hard. I thought they fell on the floor.
Okay. And then I was like, what's going on?
And then I looked behind and there was this guy standing up and it's that guy.
And he's like, well, I don't know where my bag is. And the stewardess is like,
okay, well we'll find it. And he was like, I don't know which one.
I don't know where it is. He couldn't remember where he put his bag dude,
up on the top of the thing. He found one, he was like,
I have a computer bag back there somewhere. It's like, okay, well we'll find it.
We've got to get it. We gotta get him off the plane. He was so drunk.
They got him off the plane that kicked him off the plane because he was drunk.
And then the PA pilot goes like this.
Sometimes people tend to take advantage of the, uh, the bars in the airport.
And uh,
unfortunately DFA does not like it when people have had a
couple extra drinks and it's not safe for passengers or
the crew. So let's get an a,
I'll do the best we can and get you there as quickly and safely.
Thank you for your patience.
They kicked him off.
So we went back to the gate and then we started to leave
again. And this tell, she's not drunk. Now she's talking like this.
Before you run into the plane, check
out the baggage claim area.
And for those of you that are continuing on merit cases automatically even
transfer for you. Oh,
what is she.
Bro? I was like this. I was on a plane like this
and nobody's paying attention. I'm like, this girl is drunk as, dude.
You're right. And see the plane check out. The bag is
[inaudible].
And I've just been traveling to new Erik.
Your life has been trapped for you.
Your luggage has been trapped for you. Okay.
There's there's and then there's this one dude, which is just.
RCN.
Ah.
I said that's when she almost threw up in her mouth. I see a
Customer of hers in life. That's what she said. Hold on. Just listen to it.
One of them is now RC.
Maybe have her to help. You want to hear? We have her so I can say baseline
pleasure having you on board.
Ah,
dude. Kick her off too.
It's been a pleasure having you on board Aaron in the
morning.
How? Okay. Here's the thing. If she's not drunk,
then she's got a speech impediment. I feel for you.
Why are you the one that's talking to everybody on the plane, dude.
I'm so sick of this, man.
We were also in trying to fly home and the guy that they try
there. Oh dude, the airports are insane, dude.
I swear to God if I saw and I'm I mean, no.
If I saw a wild boar working the desk at like one of the airlines,
I would be like, that's weird, but I, you know, yeah. I guess it makes sense.
This is why everything's so up. Like it's it's insane,
dude. I was, we were, we were waiting and the guy who was talking to the people,
first of all, everyone's in line, the flights delayed we're at the airport.
Okay. And everyone's in line and,
and the guy who is on the over the loudspeaker is like,
uh, he's so Indian and that's fine to be Indian,
but this guy was killing it with the Indian. I mean, he was just like lovely
[inaudible] and everyone. And I caught that. He was like flights delayed. Um,
and we will be boarding soon and people are just lined up. Dude,
sit the down, dude.
What are you? We're all getting on the plane. All of us.
So getting on the plane, also the people who are lined up aren't even group.
Hey, and guess who group guests. Hey daddy.
And he's sitting all the way down, man. His knees are bad, dude.
You keep your legs straight.
You better be laying the down because that's crazy to be lined up when the
flight's delayed and you got this guy who's telling us the flight's delayed.
We're all going to the same place. I don't get it. I don't.
I'm so sorry. Yeah, we couldn't understand this guy because he was just,
they always give it to the guy who like can't talk in English, which is,
you know, and I'm not, I'm not saying like, Hey, learn the language.
Like I'm not,
I love that America has got all the different types of people in all the
different cultures and all the different accents. It's awesome.
You might as well just speak in your language though.
If you're going to do that. I don't, I can't understand.
I sound so 80 years old right now.
Um, but yeah man, we got an oxygen mask and an oxygen also.
Don't if the person is drunk,
oxygen is the number one word that you're can tell that's what the thing should
be. If you're a cop. Okay. Or have you been drinking? No. Say the word oxygen,
oxygen. Cool. You're coming with me. If you have one drink,
all of a sudden oxygen turns to acid in said customer service,
customer service say oxygen, oxygen. Okay. You're coming with me.
Come on in the drunk tank. Woo. Are you drunk? No, sir. I don't.
You can be so good at hiding it. Oh sir. I'm completely not drunk.
Are you drunk? No, not at all. How many drinks have you had? My,
I had one drink at dinner and that's it? Uh, really? Yes. And uh,
you had another drink? Zero other drinks. Well sir, say oxygen. Oxygen.
All right, cool. You're coming with me.
Um, yeah, kicked off.
Imagine getting, he was so not embarrassed to,
I guess it was because he was drunk. It was killer. This guy was like, Oh,
you kicked me off. Cool. He was making a scene. He was like, cool.
I'll just get off the plane. Like this guy. I would have been like, yo listen,
sorry. I had too much to drink. Give me some bread.
Give me some bread and a muzzle. I'll be fine. Tie my hands up. I'm getting it.
JFK
dude, oxygen, you know? Wow.